опзж дуже себе комфортно почуває в
парламенті залишається на посадах там
заступників секретарів комітетів їздять
у відрядження міжнародні закриті в тому
числі ну знаєте там до наших партнерів
де обговорюється Питання збройної
дійсної підтримки Мають доступ до
державної таємниці І от Наша команда в
Верховній Раді України зареєструвала
низку постанов і проектів законів щодо
того як юридично оце кубло розплутати
Голова Верховної Ради і слуги її не
помічають Чому тому що давно немає в
Верховній Раді України ніякої
монобільшості немає 226 за жоден
законопроект навіть коли він приходить
від президента Зеленського і для цього
потрібні їм донори донорами виступають
якщо мова йде про якусь гадость
лубійську або корупцію обов'язково там
буде опзж